من على متن طائره العوده من الصين قرر
الرئيس الفرنسي ان يحلق عكس الرياح
الامريكيه والاوروبيه ليخرج بتصريحات
مفادها على اوروبا الا تصبح اوروبا تابعه
للولايات المتحده انهى مكرون زياره
استغرقت ثلاثه ايام ليخرج بهذه النصيحه ان
على اوروبا ان تقلص ارتباطها بالولايات
المتحده وان تتجنب مواجهه محتمله مع الصين
بشان تايوان ماكرون قال ان الخطر الكبير
الذي قد تواجهه اوروبا هو الوقوع في ازمات
ليست ازماتها مؤكدا انه ليس من مصلحه
اوروبا تسريع ازمه تايوان وبناء موقفها
بالتبعيه للولايات المتحده او بتلميحات من
الصين معتبرا انه في حال اشتدت التوترات
بين هاتين القوتين فلن يكون لاوروبا الوقت
ولا الموارد
لتمويل استقلالها الاستراتيجي واضاف
ماكرون ان على اوروبا تقليل اعتمادها على
الدولار الامريكي خارج الحدود الاقليميه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات